you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is video 15
from the beginner to chess master
playlist which is a progressive series
of videos and I'd like to discuss what I
consider to be an extremely important
topic and that is targets within a pawn
structure we're going to have some
practice here I have several examples
we'll see first and foremost what a
target is within a structure we'll see
some examples of this we'll see how we
can be pinpointing that target how we
can be hitting our opponent where they
are weakest in other words we'll see how
we can in some cases be creating what I
call an accessible target and of course
with this information on targets we want
to see how we can apply it like always
how we can be better decision-makers as
a result of this information now I know
for many of you listening watching right
now and especially for those of you who
have already gone through all the videos
up into this video here number 15 for
many of you you may be thinking man it's
starting to sound a little technical you
know he's talking about a target within
a structure and you know I'm still
player who many times before I reach
move ten I'm dropping upon a minor piece
both maybe more I feel that this is a
topic that really cannot come soon
enough and one of the objectives I have
by sharing this topic as early as I am
is to help give your mind some direction
it's a complicated game we know this and
our mind can be pulled in many different
directions plenty of distractions can
occur on the board we get all sorts of
crazy ideas I'm hopeful that this will
give you something to focus on I'm
hopeful that this will help you to
better appreciate the pawns
and how delicate you ought to be with
their every movement let me say that and
just a single target within your own
pawn structure can have a tremendous
domino effect on your whole position one
weakness can mean that your other pieces
now have to watch over that weakness and
protect it if you're creating a target
you're playing against an experienced
player the Sharks of the chessboard you
can be sure that that one target is like
blood to them they will not only know
where the target is but they will be on
to that target and you will soon enough
be eaten alive
now with that said now that I have you
have scared to death let's dive into our
first example I have several of them
here 12 let's have a look at this first
one where I'm going to throw a pop quiz
at you how about that as a start okay
this is the first position I'd like you
to have a look out where it is white to
move
let me also mention blacks last move was
Rick to be eight to give you a little
bit of a hint here okay rook to b8 what
would you do in this position as white
if you'd like to go ahead pause the
video I encourage that go ahead pause
the video see what you would come up
with okay
now white is in a difficult spot no
matter what no matter what white does
they're in a difficult spot the best
move is to play b3 if you said rook to
b1 this is a case of having one of your
pieces be responsible for the defensive
upon and this is the first note I'd like
to make generally speaking we should
have our pawns be responsible for
defending pawns we don't want to have
our pieces tied down to the defensive
upon this is an inconvenience well is it
really that bad well in this example
here you can be sure it is I'm showing
you a very extreme example right now
yeah this is really bad if you're
defending the pawn with the rook in this
case you know why because this rook one
day will probably have something else
more important to do like defend made on
g2 and when he comes over here there
goes the beep on
we don't want to have the short story
here is that we don't want to have our
pieces responsible for watching over
ponds and this may help this may
reinforce something that was shared in
an earlier video where I spoke of pond
Islands this is one of the reasons why
it's nice to have pond Islands ponds
functioning in groups have ponds
together so in the event one of the one
of the ideas is so that in the event one
of them is attacked at least there's a
neighbor around like the a pond and the
C pond I can watch over it okay which
means that our rook the other pieces are
free to do other stuff like in this case
defend against a mate threat on g2 okay
it's our first example let's have a look
at another one related to this this idea
this position right here where it is
white to move and well this isn't going
to be a pop quiz let me just tell you
black is better okay many of you may
have been able to quickly identify this
and let me just give a couple reasons as
to why black is better it's because this
rook is on a very good rank and prevents
the white king from
being a inactive piece he can't he can
never really cross the second-ranked for
as long as the brook stays here and he's
just going to have a very difficult time
becoming active and playing a role on
this end game now it wasn't always this
bad okay let's have a look at how we
actually got to this position this is
where we were at one point before the
ruck was on the second-ranked this is
where we were at one point and in this
position with white to move let me tell
you that white made the move Bishop to
b3 instead of having a pawn watch over
the pawn by playing b3 and it's a
actually a pretty level like position
here instead of having that move played
what white did was play Bishop to b3 and
one of the drawbacks with having a piece
devoted to defending upon and in this
case the bishop is at least for the
moment defending against rook captures
pawn one of the drawbacks with having a
piece defend upon like this is that it
is vulnerable to the tactic of
deflection after Bishop b3 we had a for
Bishop takes pawn rook takes pawn now
both of these guys are hit the bishop
comes here to defend rook takes pawn
does this look familiar that's how we
got to this position right here and it
came about as a result of white devoting
a piece to the defense of a pawn again
in general when one of our pawns is
attacked ideally if we're if we're
needing to defend it in very often we
will be needing to defend it we don't
want to give away free pawns where we're
not going to be that generous type of
player we don't want to give away free
material if we're going to protect it
ideally we would like to have pawns
fulfill that responsibility we want to
have pawns fulfill that role
okay now with that said let's have a
look at how our opponent can be creating
targets let's see this first example and
this if you've gone through this
playlist up into this point this is a an
example here that I have already shared
twice this is a third time I'm sharing
it um and I don't know if I'll share I
don't know if I'll share it again but
it's just such a instructive and popular
mistake that happens in chess games that
I just have to show it again and I
learned something new about this example
that I'm showing right now that I I just
I have to share it with you it's just I
don't know
it's mind-boggling this this number that
I'm about to share with you here we go
we have D for this is all pretty common
right you see this a 45 right very
common Knight f3 night out night out
attacker defender everything's cool d 4e
takes D night takes D so far so good
Knight takes Knight we already know from
previous videos this is a time mistake
great and now we have the move well we
have the moves c5 but before we get to
this point let me say that on one of the
online databases I looked at with lower
level games this next move here Knight
takes Knight you know how many times
this move is played it's a very popular
move in fact the most popular from this
lower level bracket of games that I've
looked at seven thousand five hundred
and twenty three players make this move
and it is not good it's a time mistake
it doesn't stop there because once we're
in this position I believe it was the
second or third most popular move was c5
1196 I'm sure this number got is higher
I'm just looking at a very small pool of
games here but yeah aren't those neat
aren't those numbers a bit like
unbelievable you know this is a player
who captures here because they have fear
of a my Knights going to be captured and
I'm going to have doubled see pawns you
know that's a time mistake and then this
right here c5 this is a weakness is this
is what I'm talking about
where you know you just created black
right now created with this last move
they created some targets where's the
target this is a hole this is a hole
well where exactly is a target in this
in this position well really it's this
pawn right here I don't care where he
goes he's a target for the rest of the
game d6 is where he ends up let's just
fast forward a little bit Queen D 3 d6
this is a target
now I'm only going to show a a few
examples in this video but how can we
identify a target in a position let me
give you something to to chew on a
target you can identify you know first
identify where is there a hole within my
opponents position which one of the
black pawns is a target well a pond that
sits on a hole that's probably a target
this is a target right now who's going
to defend them not a pond so what does
this mean
pieces Bishop Queen now have a
responsibility to watch over the pun how
do things play out in this brief game
here what do we do we pinpoint the
target Bishop here queenside castle
there's already three pieces hitting
here and you can't even you can't even
really defend him at this point it's
he's already down we're not we're 10
moves into the game blacks already
busted this is an example where black
creates a target on his own we need to
be able to identify this okay as soon as
c5 is played we should already be
thinking to ourself wow thanks a lot
that's a really that's a real nice
target for us to pinpoint we're going to
win that pawn this is a this is a very
unhealthy pawn now let's have a look at
another example this one right here
let's see how a target can be created
and maybe it's not so clear that a
target is created in this one let's get
some moves in here where we now have
moved e5 now watch what happens next
maybe this is something you can relate
to Black's last move okay d5 now watch
what happens you ready he takes the he
takes D what does white to see takes T
black recaptures
his white to-night takes the black
recaptures what does white do
unfortunately there's nothing more for
white to recapture or there's nothing
more for white to capture this is this
is a take happy player okay they what
did they just do they captured they
captured again captured again until they
can capture no more okay until they are
left with now a dead pawn right here
well he's not completely dead but he's
backward he's isolated he is now without
the support of any other white pawn he
is weak he is blood to the shark this
guy right here
and I'm sure white was just completely
unaware of this being a deficiency it's
this is a take happy player capture
capture until you can capture no more
and in the end you're now saddled with
this target right here on the D file
isolated not all isolated pawns or
weaknesses but this one here certainly
is sometimes if you can get your
isolated pawn functioning on your own
fourth-ranked there are some benefits to
that of course but not this guy here
he's not going anyways not getting to
the fourth-ranked he's getting to the
third-ranked and he'll soon be captured
let me just play out a few more moves
and this is how well this is how play it
on a little bit bishop there actually it
went like this
Queen c4 this is what black could be
doing capture capture queenside castle
and soon we can be having the rooks
pinpointing this pawn right here he is
soon to fall this is an evaluation
that's approaching already minus two in
favor of well minus 2 this is an
advantage for black and it's related to
this pawn right here he's just no good
he is soon to be dropping off look at
Bishop takes Knight and we could already
even jump into this hole in the position
and look at another
Holzer just holes everywhere there's
this weakness this isolated ponds
squares on the same file is that
isolated pawn or holes tremendous effect
on the whole position having just a
single target on board and this came as
a result in this example this was a 8
just a take happy player they just take
take take take take until you can take
no more something that was maybe a
little bit better is to play the move d4
right now right now while you can get
the move in so that you are exchanging a
onion unhealthy pond for one who is
perfectly healthy one who should it be
attacked can always have the support of
the B pond why can't say that about the
deep on so this is actually the one
moment white should be looking to get
rid of their liability so identifying
ponds in other words as healthy or
unhealthy this is your moment okay you
have a you have an unhealthy pond right
here this is your moment right now
timing is everything in this position
this is your moment to get rid of your
unhealthy pond for a perfectly healthy
pawn on c5 because you didn't do that
because you're excited about making a
capture in this case d4 right now
thanks for the free pawn Knight takes
pawn that may not even be best there's
Bishop here giving a pin and there's
also that time element of course black
is ahead time wise here
d4 needed to be played right now okay
but because white didn't do that they
were left with this deficient pawn on D
to this target on the D file let's have
a look at another example here one that
is a little bit more advanced I pointed
out that well you know how do we
identify a target you know it identify
the holes within the enemy position if
they have a pond that is on that resides
on a hole then that is a potential
target now this one is a little bit more
of an advanced structure
not going to go through how you know I'm
just going to kind of breeze past this
opening stage where is the target for
black actually right here we can already
say at this point let's just say this
much as soon as this move was played we
can already say that this is a hole
guess who ends up there soon deep on
this is a hole this is a weakness this
is something that whites soon targets
with the bishop and soon enough with a
couple King Knight moves boom and then
BOOM sure enough what's happening here
white is converging on the weakest point
within the black position don't don't be
too I don't know how to say don't don't
feel like oh how I'm going to remember
this this isn't something you have to
this isn't a how do I commit this to
memory thing this is you know this is a
target because of these definitions we
know what a hole is if there's a pawn
that resides on that square that's
likely target okay how we could then
look to develop our pieces deploy pieces
in a way where they put pressure on that
what does this mean what kind of domino
effect does this have on the black
position well you can be sure that the
Queen can't go too far she has to watch
over that there's two attackers
currently and black actually on this
very next move needs another defender so
he has to do something like run and
reverse to defend like that or play
Knight here and block the bishops direct
view of d6 okay
neither is fun okay the point here is
identify the target in put pressure on
it the end what's going to happen is
that your opponent is then having to
take up a defensive posture and these
pieces will now have some they will be
restricted in some way let's have a look
at also one more just on this idea of
targets here one more from an example
from a game I actually played in a
serious tournament and over the board
game this was actually from 2007 and
this
that I created this YouTube channel
actually let's get to this one key
position I'm playing as white by the way
I was a a master at this point and so
too was my opponent and this is the
position I want to draw your attention
to I had a very important decision to
make in this game and I overlooked an
idea that black had in this at this
point it's my turn to move and what I
did was play rook a to d1 and just to
give a brief reason why my idea was to
play Knight to d2 in exchange off this
strongly placed night I wanted to have a
night for Knight exchange what I
overlooked was blacks a next move and
that is the move b5 ok now what is the
move b5 doing it's clearly challenging
my c4 pawn and I have a very important
decision to make
do I capture or do I move forward and I
must do one of the two because otherwise
I'm just going to be losing upon so what
should I do in this position some of you
may be aware of this game that I've
played and may know the answer already
but I'll throw it to you
pop quiz number I don't know I forget
how many pop quizzes I've already thrown
on you but what would you do in this
position here it's white to move what
would you do
ok the move I played was c5 why well if
I capture like this or this the
structure will end up the same there'll
be a b5 pawn and a d5 pawn whether I
capture like this or this and the end
result is that I have a C pawn here that
is backward which one of my pawns will
be watching over him none there's none
around and you could be sure that black
will put some more pressure on the C
pawn there's already a knight hitting it
you can be sure that the Queen's the
rooks they will be exerting some
pressure maybe the Queen somehow
finds a way to come over here and in the
end all I saw is that I would be on the
defensive I'd be having to tend to this
target on my own end the c3 pawn is a
target and black will be on it and I
will have to devote maybe multiple
pieces to its defense that's not a good
position to be in
therefore that's why I made the decision
to play C 5 so that this pawn it's still
target the knight as pressure on it but
it's not as accessible is it I'm not
allowing in this case the rooks to
pinpoint the c3 pawn ok that's a little
bit more of an advanced example the
first two I showed you it's pretty you
know the c5 move and that earlier
example attacking the Queen that's
pretty clear oh my goodness you're
really weakening your D pawn by doing
that this one is a little bit more
advanced okay but ok let's go on and see
another example here on this topic of
targets here we go let's see how knowing
what pawns are targets and what ones are
not targets identifying a healthy and
unhealthy pawns can have us make good
decisions bad decisions in some case ok
this should look familiar
Knight takes Queen takes in this case
they don't play black doesn't play c5
here but instead d6 okay no no great
targets in blacks position just yet
Bishop b5 check ok c6 is played alright
throwing a punch back at the bishop
there's already a target this pawn
doesn't need to be on c5 in order for d6
to be a target this pawn is weak this is
a target now no black pawns around that
can help support the pond from its
current post on d6 Bishop gets out of
the way we get some development and and
what do we have happen in this game this
this is a game that actually was played
here why in this position played the
movie 5 now if white understood that
this is something that's weak this
is something that you can maybe pick up
and not even have to invest your own
pond you know why go for a pond for pawn
exchange why not just win this outright
why played the movie 5 and what we're
basically having here is a perfectly
healthy on a strong pond being traded
for one that is weak white helped black
out with that move I don't know there's
there seems to be at least a lower level
I see this you know seems like there's
infatuation with moving ponds in order
to attack minor pieces or major pieces
and you know white wasn't aware clearly
that hey this is a weak bond you should
be looking to pick him up
Bishop f4 queenside castle similar to
what we already saw and he may very well
just fall pinpoint the target the target
in this case is d6 this is a hole
there's a black pawn that resides on it
we have an exchange instead and actually
just from that little exchange it is
already black who stands a little bit
better here let's have a look at another
example this one right here
where it is white to move treat this as
another pop quiz light to move what
would you do in this position okay the
best move here is a three if we do a
scan of the pawn structure on the black
side we should be able to identify that
this guy right here on d6 is yet again
weak okay I know many of the examples
it's just the d6 pawn over and over and
over again but okay we have a pond
that's weak on d6 now should we be so
quick to grab that pond you know you
have a little bit of patience here let's
let's recognize this guy's hit three
times defended zero we take him he takes
him is that really good trade no you
gotta be kidding me this pond in a2 is
perfectly healthy let's save him he's
strong this guy's weak we're not going
to go for that exchange if you value
this pond if you give this guy the same
weight as this one
you're way off he's a dead duck this guy
is really strong save him and only one
move later can you be picking up this
paan free-of-charge have a little
patience here identify the the target
identified the healthy and unhealthy
puns don't be going for this kind of
exchange where you take an unhealthy
pond and you allow your opponent to take
a perfectly healthy pond no way ok let's
have a look at how many more examples do
I have just a few here is another one
okay now the ponds are talking to you
how receptive are you to the ponds I
said in my introduction to this video
that you know we're going to be having a
look at some examples where we create
accessible targets let's see what I mean
by that in this example efore be 6 d 4 D
5 e 5 there is already a lot we can say
about this position the ponds are are
really talking to us right now
they're they're giving us some direction
they're telling us in what direction of
the board we should be playing on we're
already aware that we need to be making
a pond break it's already been
emphasized creating a pond duo is a good
idea
Black's next move a good move is C 5
it's good because it's a move that's
creating a pond break it's creating a
pond duo and it's good for another
reason the one that I'm going to touch
on now it's helpful in one day creating
a our creating an accessible target
namely a white pawn on d4
now let me just throw a couple numbers
at you just like I did in that in that
one variation where the the night is
captured on d4 and then the pawn comes
up to attack the Queen here's a couple
numbers that you might that might
interest you again pulling this these
numbers here from the one database
online from some lower level games but
still knight c6 you know not a losing
move by any means but it's one that's
kind of you know not familiar player who
plays this is just not familiar with the
direction one should be going in 1372
games had moved three in this position
right here move three be knight c6 no
this is a fine place for the night but
only after the C punt has played here
why well I don't care if you have the
knight attacking the pawn
one day the bishop let's say on this b6
square hitting the pawn the Queen both
rooks your neighbor and your grandmother
it doesn't matter this pawn is going
nowhere it doesn't matter how many
pieces you pile up on this guy all white
has to do is just kind of limp in here
c3 he's defended by just one pawn I
don't care how many pieces you direct on
this until you crack at the d4 pawn with
the C pawn or in other words until the C
pawns have been exchanged until the D
pawn has been stripped of its only
defender right c5 c3 chop-chop what just
happened to see pawns have been
exchanged until that exchange occurs
this square here is not a target so we
want to be able to create an accessible
target here by first playing c5 a very
common reply good reply here for white
is to support d4 with a pawn why is this
so it's because when this pawn is
captured we can recapture and have
support for our head pawn here if we
don't have a pawn support and E 5 this
may be the new target that black and
pinpoint with moves like knight c6 Queen
c7 maybe this Knight takes a couple
steps in pinpoints 'if I've from the g6
square again this is in cases where
there isn't a white pawn on d4 defending
ee5 let's see how this game played out
black develops what is he doing he's
putting some pressure on this target
Point D for white develops in defense
some more so far let's let's take stock
of the d4 square just at this moment
here what do we have attackers lies we
have one attacker two attackers and does
white atleast have two defenders one two
yes even has a third
so so far white is okay white has
satisfactory defense more than enough
defense of d4 as it stands right now
let's get some more development in
Bishop d3
excuse me Bishop d7 and now we have
Bishop d3 it seems like a pretty good
diagonal not necessarily best as we'll
soon find out I don't want to get into
those details but it seems natural
enough right development we put our
Bishop on d3 what does a black to next
Queen b6 this adds another attacker
notice the bishop on d3 also gets in the
Queen's way of defending d4 what is
black what is really happening here
black is applying pressure to the d4
pawn and there are certain concessions
white needs to make there's certain
restriction placed on the white position
the knight has to defend upon the Queen
has to defend the d4 pawn right right
now white white runs the risk of
actually losing the d4 pawn as it stands
right now
one two three pieces are attacking d4
and there is only two defenders so white
could maybe move the bishop again but
that's not really something you would
want to do moving another piece you know
there could even be this kind of stuff
happening this is getting a little bit
involved if you want to save the bishop
maybe this Knight one day jumps into a
hole there's certain concessions that
could come about as a result of being
any restricted position like this where
you have to babysit this pawn this isn't
this isn't losing by any means but I'm
just trying to emphasize how applying
pressure to a a weak point eight putting
pressure on a target within your
opponent's structure can influence their
pieces how they could now be limited and
not it not as free anymore
one other note is that in this position
stay away from this move is black and it
may be very tempting to you maybe maybe
this is this is what you still do as a
player here you're playing as black if
this is a move right now that you're
considering c4 wow you need to back up
here because if the only reason you're
assigning for a pawn move is hey maybe
I'm going to win that Bishop if he
doesn't move no that's not good enough
you need to have a better reason besides
that because let me just tell you this
much to an experienced player you know
I'll just I'll phrase it like this if I
see this move play it against me um it's
like I write I want to write you a thank
you letter thank you so much for
attacking my bishop you know I see that
the bishop is attacked okay I'm going to
get out of the way but what I really
like the most and you know this is what
I would emphasize in that letter it's
thank you so much you know I don't have
to watch over my D pun anymore my knight
he's so much more free my queen she
doesn't have to babysit D for things are
grand thank you so much okay you should
be looking to capture on d4
and by doing so you are creating an
accessible target look at how your
pieces just come out Queen v6 you're
immediately applying pressure to d4 okay
this isn't to say that this would and
that this would never be a good idea
because I will be showing an example
where actually taking a step like this
is in fact a an interesting home well it
is a good idea but there are other
there's a certain there's another piece
of criteria a very important piece of
criteria that we need to be looking into
I might as well just say it now know
that the king does not reside over here
on the Queen side maybe this actually
would be an idea if the king the most
valuable piece resided over here because
this pawn could be a bit cramping to
what okay but as it is right now c4 is
dunno a bad move because it releases the
pressure on d4 this is no longer
something white has to watch over this
is no longer a target this is no longer
an accessible target if black wants to
create an some target he would have to
get this pawn going all the way down
here and strike at c3 let me also point
out the following right here okay just
from these few moves in what black is
doing by playing the move c5 is striking
at the tail of White's pawn structure
okay this is almost always a very good
thing to do okay we can identify the
head and tail the pawn structure if we
look at the fixed the fixed pawns here
in on board for white this is the head
pawn and this is the tail pawn okay and
for black this is the head pawn the
furthest advanced pawn and this is the
tail pawn okay it is almost always a
good idea to strike at the tail of your
opponent's pawn structure
see five is the way to go and I was
saying earlier about how the pawns are
talking to you how they're helping you
helping to give you some direction know
in on what side of the board you should
be playing on well suppose we do this
this may be helpful to you if you draw a
line from the base of your own pawn
chain to the head excuse me let's say
like this if you draw a line from the
tail of your pawn chain to the head this
is the direction you should be going in
this is the side of the board you should
be planning on on the Queen side the
pawns are pointing in the direction
where you should be playing ideally
where you should be looking for that
pawn break so in this case the pawns are
saying hey play on the Queen side
they're pointing in that direction again
drawing a line from the tail of the pawn
chain to the head c5 is the way to go
white is there to reinforce on a good
day and with enough preparation this may
not be so easily accomplished white
isn't able to get upon here in just one
move but ideally if there was enough
time and white had enough preparation he
would be looking to do similar which is
to say you know if we draw a line from
the tail to the head this is the
direction white should be playing in or
in other words on the Kings side and so
ideally this pawn would really like to
be right next to to the furthest
advanced pawn right next to his buddy
here up on the f5 square that will take
a little bit more prep work but if
you're able to make one pawn move and
immediately strike at the tail of your
opponent's pawn structure probably a
good thing okay there's really no
downside to doing that if we are to
strike sometimes you'll see you know
sometimes you'll have it where you
strike it not only the tail
of your opponent's pawn structure but
also the head so in this case we're
having the the pawn strike at the tail
he can also strike at the head but do
know this much do know that if you are
striking at the head of your opponent's
pawn chain in this specific example at
least if you are striking at the head of
your opponent's pawn structure know that
with that type of strike there is a
deficiency you are actually creating
some target within your own pawn
structure now how is this so why is this
so well after let's say Knight to f3
supposed black just go straight in and
captures here Knight takes pawn where
are there holes in this position B 5
just like that after just a couple moves
there's already a gap in blacks position
on the e5 square f6 striking at the head
if you're going to do this there's some
deficiency it's not always bad don't get
me wrong
but I just want to bring to your
attention that there are some weaknesses
that occur in your within your own
position if you are striking at the head
of your opponent's pawn chain f6 is an
example of this striking at the head
pawn right here Knight f3 takes takes
this Knight is already in a hole within
the black position and the e pawn he is
backward to be sure that there'll be
some pressure placed on him by some
heavy pieces the rooks in the Queen's
okay so there's some drawback is what
I'm getting out it's all I want to draw
your attention to you don't get that
deficient there is no deficiency if
you're if you're making this move how is
how is black creating some structural
weakness some target there isn't
anything okay there isn't a there isn't
a great drawback okay we could say that
this is a this is a hole on the d6
square but having a target within black
zone pawn structure as a result of c5
there isn't any okay so we have to be
just a little bit delicate here do
striking at the tail is fine at the head
there may be some drawback with that now
let me just play out a few more moves
from this game here and well as it was
played out there was so much pressure on
d4 white decided to give it up and so as
mentioned just a little bit earlier I
said well if this pawn is never around
maybe e5 then becomes a target well sure
enough that's what black does he goes to
c7 and all of a sudden there's not
enough defense for it it struck at twice
only defended once so what is white do
well he has to defend Bishop f4 and then
black gets another piece involved and
then white just you know continues to
develop white has enough support for it
right two defenders only two attackers
whites that's satisfactory good enough
but then comes knight g6 and just like
that this has hit a third time and the
bishop is attacked oh no there's already
some concession white needs to make
because of black putting pressure on
this target what are you going to do the
bishop backs up you're already dropping
a pawn so I mean I guess one of the
better things white can do here is give
up the bishop for Knight and you know
this is a this is a fine position for
black I would prefer black here having
you know this open file here and having
two bishops so the short story here is
that applying pressure on our opponent
identifying this target creating an
accessible target here kicking out from
this move what move three creating
striking at it with first c5 hitting at
the tail of our opponent structure soon
we have something to focus on we have
something to pinpoint and put pressure
on we're restricting our opponent pieces
now have to have the responsibility for
watching over that pawn okay let's have
a look at I just have two more examples
this next one is I think I don't think
it will take very long at all this is
one where two players played in a way
where they just weren't aware of
striking at the head or the tail the
pawn chain they did none of the above in
fact in this position right here you
know what white did they
like d5 this is something I find is
quite common in the games of lower level
players they just I don't know I'm not I
can't explain I don't know why and the
move is played but yeah just and I know
you move upon to d5 I don't know it's a
different story let me say this much if
it's a different story if this pawn is
played here and this pawn was already
you know up here because notice how the
structure is formed right now it's a
it's inverted from what we just looked
at look at the tail
look at the head this is the direction
white should be going in playing on the
Queen side of the board whereas black
the pawns drawing it from the tail to
the head pointing towards the Kings side
this is the direction black should be
playing in or in other words they should
be looking right now or at least soon
they should be looking for an f5 break
okay to put some pressure on this point
to have it at a point where the knight
is able to be on f6 and exerting
pressure on this Square this never
happened in this game the move d5 was
played and then there was just a lot of
peace movements neither side went for
some type of pawn break ideally this
pawn should be looking to get up here on
c5 but none of that happened the the
players were just kind of shuffling
about we had just a very silly type move
Knight b5 a 6 and then the knight goes
back to c3 so clearly this was a game
that I came across where we just have
players who aren't creating the correct
kind of pond break they're not playing
in the correct direction
they're just unaware of these type of
pawn breaks what side of the board they
should really be looking to play on okay
now I have just one last example here
let me bring it up there we go and this
is an opening here that is very popular
many great game
games have been played out of this one
and you could be sure that every player
at the higher levels of course are well
aware of the direction we should be
going in they're aware that the pawns
are giving giving us direction they're
telling us where we should be looking to
play and with this last move here now
that we have some type of defined
central structure these are the examples
these are not the only examples but
these are two key examples to be showing
where we have fixed pawns in the center
the E and D pawns are fixed how they are
staggered how they are positioned will
help us know in what direction we should
be looking to play on board okay and
with this last move we could already add
an already identified the tail and the
head in what direction should white be
playing drawing from the tail to the
head Queen side pawns are pointing in
that direction we should be looking for
a c5 pawn break and one of the reasons
we are doing this is so that we can
create something to bite out not the
only reason but that's one of the
reasons we can be creating an accessible
target a way to enter into our
opponent's position how play follows in
this little example we have Knight to e1
this is preparing to get the knight here
where he facilitates this c5 pawn move
there's not yet enough support for it
also he is getting out of the way of the
F pawn so that the F pawn can defend
efore White is anticipating that it will
be struck out and this is the way that
black will be playing right going from
the tail to the head this is the
direction black will be looking to play
namely on the Queen side Rick's to me
the Kings side white looks to play on
the Queen side black is looking to play
on the King side just the the pawn
structure in the center alone is giving
us that information I'll play follows
was Knight d7 93
5f three and now we have the move f4
which previously I said you know this is
releasing some pressure in the earlier
example I was talking about well you
know I'm going to write my opponent a
thank-you letter if this was I think how
I phrased it and that was similar to
kind of what we're seeing here with this
pun you know just advancing here notice
in this example it's a little bit
different in the main reason it's
different is because black knows that
the king resides on this sector of the
board in this section
white white has already declared his
Kings intention we didn't have that in
the previous example so what Black's
idea really is to attack the white king
okay and that's this the kind of game
that we have that's why there's so many
interesting games that stem from this
opening that I'm sharing with you right
now this sequence of moves that I have
now on board a lot of interesting games
come about from this and what we now
have is an extended pawn chain it's
still the same story so far I've only
shown examples of where it was like two
pawns drawing from the tail to the head
well now the headed prong is a little
bit different this is the tail this is
the head but it's still the same story
okay this is still the direction black
wants to play in and this is the next
pawn break black should be looking to
get in again the pawns are giving us
some direction here okay
black is looking for this pawn break and
to have some half open file and get at
the white king okay but the main point
here is to recognize what's what side of
the board should we be playing on how
are the pawns actually giving us some
instructions okay just playing it out a
few more just to give you a feel
Brooksie one we could already play as
white c5 this is a little sacrifice of
upon just to get some play on the
queenside
chop chop Knight b4 and then b5 this is
the direction white is looking to play
in the short the short story here on the
queenside black is looking to play on
the Kings side the pawns tell us that
the rook can maybe post up on c6 okay
this is getting a little bit beyond the
scope of what I really wanted to cover
in this video one other thing I want to
point out is that if black you know
doesn't capture on this square suppose I
don't know suppose just gets on with
trying to get this type of advance in or
swings the knight over here preparing to
get this kind of pawn break in next we
can have maybe some capture and then all
of a sudden this pawn is maybe a little
bit vulnerable notice he no longer has
the defense of any other black pawns and
so this Queen at the very least will now
have a certain responsibility she'll
have to tend to that pawn and there
could maybe even be more fuel added to
that point with the move like Bishop to
b4 and who knows maybe even the Queen
comes over and exerts pressure on this
newly created target okay so this is one
of the things you get when you attack
your opponent in the correct way if
you're attacking your opponent's pawn
structure in the right way what can
result here is an accessible target
something that you can be putting
pressure on and as a result of that
pressure your opponent's pieces now have
a certain restriction or defensive
responsibility they have to watch over
these targets is that all I wanted to
say with this video I have no idea how
long it's been going on but there was a
lot covered in here at 12 examples to
share with you
pawns are a big deal it's the short
story need to be very delicate with them
recognize the weaknesses you may be
creating with with a pawn move you know
backward pawn isolated pawn just a
single target is Ollie really good
player needs to make your life difficult
okay so again as mentioned at the start
I was my hope that you know drawing
attention to this is going to be helpful
to you
being attentive being very attentive to
the ponds we don't want to be creating
weaknesses we don't want to give our
opponent something to bite out okay we
see some examples of how we could we saw
some examples how we could be creating
accessible targets this is again a big
big deal and again it was my hope part
part of my hope here was to again a
raise your awareness of the ponds and
how important they really are in the
game okay so with that said as usual I
hope you're able to take something away
from this video and I look forward to
sharing video 16 with you that's all for
now take care bye
you